even your monotheist and your unitarian
i'm a monotheist and i'm a trinitarian
so you're monotheist and unitarian
because you believe there's one person
who's god
and there is only one person who is
divine
i'm monotheist because i believe there's
one person who's god but i'm trinitarian
because i believe yet
there are three persons who are divine
divine the all-knowing
yeah the all-powerful the all-seeing the
all-wise
why does he require to share his power
with other entities the question number
one is why would god
require that
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products their products are
fantastic health supplements and also
from the sunnah the website is in the
description link below you can also use
the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
so uh
uh brothers and sisters welcome to
salaam corner
we're starting again uh we're going to
try inshallah like i said before we have
joshua today
uh joshua discussion with brotherhood
hashim mohammed hijab
i've spoken to him a long long time ago
last year after we started [ __ ] as well
like i said today i want to i want to i
want to learn from him
and his belief system because there is
some
not tweaks but maybe what you may tell
me
and educate me your belief in trinity
how is it different to the common belief
and if you can just elaborate on that
okay
so yeah so i am my position is that
there are three persons in the trinity
each of them are divine fathers divine
son and the spirit are each divine
and because they are each divine we can
use the term god
in a certain sense in a predicative
sense
so we're using it as a predicate for
that being so the father is god
because he has a divine property the son
is god because he has a divine property
and divine nature and the holy spirit's
god because he has a divine property and
divine nature
however we can use the term god also in
another sense
which is called the nominal sense that
basically means
using it as a name for an entity using
as a name for a thing
so god is now is used solely as a name
for the father so if we go to scripture
and it says
there is only only one only one true god
okay
or it says um jesus says i'm going to my
father to your father my god or my god
or paul says um there is one god the
father and one lord jesus christ
what paul is saying when you paul and
jesus are saying is that yes there is
one god the father and he's the soul god
because he has the name
god and that name is applicable to him
and that name is not applicable to the
son
neither is it applicable to the spirit
however the father son and spirit are
each god like i said
at the beginning in a predicative sense
because they each have the divine
property they are each all powerful or
knowing or loving
and so forth and so what i'm saying to
you where the difference is between me
and maybe the common view is
the idea when we say who is what's the
one god
a lot of the common view would be the
one god is the trinity and i think i saw
that also in
i think a video in the past uh the
diagram one where the one god was equal
to the trinity
i would say no the one god is equal to
the father the one god is equal to one
of the persons in the trinity
so why we are monotheists is because we
believe in one person
who is one god the father however we are
trinitarians because we believe in
three persons who are each divine so
they're each divine but one of them is
god in a nominal sense as a name who is
the father and that's why we are
monotheists
sorry if it might get confused if you
want to bring i don't know it didn't
actually
i'm actually surprised by myself okay
let me get this right so you're seeing
when it comes to the title when it says
i'm going to
my god that title is referred to the
father
however in actual sense they all have
some kind of divinity
we have divinity in that so when when we
see in other parts of the bible where it
says in acts 5
the holy spirit's god or it says in
titus 2 13
that jesus is a god and savior it's
using that word god not in the same way
as a name yeah as the father it's not
using as a name
it's using it as a predicate saying they
are it's this being the holy spirit and
the and jesus christ and titus 2 is a
divine person he has
the divine properties so it's using so
god can be used in different ways that's
what i'm trying to say
that's interesting okay so now
what i want to delve into is that
firstly okay thank you very much for
educating me on that because it's very
important
that we understand where you're coming
from yes because sometimes what we do is
dawah we do dawah to our judgment
oh did you get some people do that with
us yeah they come and talk to us because
they have a judgment about islam
and we're like look that's not what
we're talking about we don't believe
that
so it's good that you've educated me and
i've learned from that and i thank you
for that joshua
why i wanted to say it was a following
when you say
the father so the father is the one who
is entitled
to the title of god like the name the
name the name the name yeah
but in essence the father the son and
the holy spirit
are divine isn't that
some kind of a hierarchy yes
okay if there is an hierarchy
it reminds me of why islam came to
arabia
and tell me if i'm wrong because the
pagan
arabs they affirmed and acknowledged
that allah is their lord so we have
in tahit the oneness of god we have
three categories
we have tawheed uh
so what that means is we affirm and
acknowledge and single out god
in his lordship so it's when we say god
is the one who's created
he did not need any other entity to
carry that lordship out he is the
ultimate lordship
now where we differ with you guys and
this is the reason why i wanted to ask
about the hierarchy and why
islam came down because islam came for
this very specific reason
that you have your belief system because
the pagan arabs
did not have free persons
who were divine and they just said for
example the only reason we go to the
statute is just to get closer to
the ultimate god which they gave a child
to like here we acknowledge he's
he's allah he's the one who's created us
we are just using them now that comes to
the second part of the tawheed
worship so what we do is we single out
god in worship because otherwise if we
didn't then there is no difference
because you said you're a monotheist
we'll say that kind of monetism is not
the monetism that we understand
that's the reason why islam came down
with a pure monotheism
and came to the pagan arabs and told
them that
you are mushriks pagans yeah in the
context of
you say we believe in allah but you've
made these handmade statues
and you're worshiping them just as the
story of ibrahim in the old times in the
quran
where they had the main idol his father
had the main idol uncle uncle
uncle there's a camera in the camera
yeah sorry forgive me sorry
it's just because it will get in the way
yeah and and and and so for example
in that in that angle um they said for
example you're
affirming god why you've got also
ibrahim so ibrahim
what he did is his father he was telling
his father look look you've made this
with your own hands
and you're worshiping it like come on
one day his father was out
and he went into this specific place
yeah and he destroyed all the statues
except the big one
and when his dad came and said what
happened to our gods he said you see
that big one
he he destroyed all of them and he said
son do you not know
that it doesn't speak how could it
destroy it well they said father
duh like in the context that's what i'm
trying to tell you
so he's trying to tell him look you've
made it with your own hands
now this is the reason why islam has
pure monotheism
because the third thing which i said
lordship worship
and his names and his attributes so we
do not give those names and attributes
to
men or the creation yeah we can't say to
a creation he's the owner we can't see
prophet muhammed is the all-knowing no
he's not good he's all-powerful no he's
not
and we do not ascribe that to mankind
now what you've told me is that even
though the title belongs to the father
and when we say
god we're actually talking about the
father even though the three of them
share the divinity this is the very
reason joshua islam came to abolish
so i'm just asking like i just want you
to understand from our perspective
what you believe how could it be true
monotheism
where you're sharing the same traits as
pagans in arabia
so um i'll just say that a distinction
needs to be made between two concepts
monotheism and monolatry
it's a weird difficult word today but
monolatry so
monologue is the worship of one entity
one being
monotheism is the belief in one being or
belief in one god
so ultimately yeah so one belief in one
ultimate
god okay that's monotheism monolatry
is just monolith
it's the worship of only one being
okay so what i'll differ with you is
that i
i'm happy to say i agree and i think
actually we share
funny enough funny enough we share
um even more things that may be a common
lesson common trinitarian will say to
you
that god is try personal god is three
persons i disagree with that
i say god is one person the father
yeah so yeah
so some common it's more lay level
common trinitarianism we'll say
god is try personal god is three persons
god is the trinity okay as you did in
that diagram before
you say god is the father god is the
father okay however each of them are
divine
and so they're god in another way in
another sense but when we're using that
monotheism god term
we're referring to the father so why we
are monotheists is because there's only
one entity one being one person
who is god in that sense and that will
be a shared thing
actually interestingly this position
with a jew and with a muslim who say
yeah god is one person god is
not three persons so we will share that
but what i'll disagree with you is the
conflation of monotheism
and monolatry i don't believe that you
need to say that oh because i believe
there's only one
god one ultimate being who we term the
father
that also we can only worship that
father i would say worship is contingent
on a being being divine so if a being
has all power
or knowledge perfectly good necessary
eternal
then it's worthy of worship it has these
properties so it's worth your worship
why i wouldn't worship that thing that
couldn't do that action is because it
lacks one of those properties it's not
all powerful
it's not all knowing it's not all this
so the reason why i worship the sun and
worship the spirit as well
is because they are equally they're
equally
the sun and the spirit are equally
worthy of worship with the father
because they are equally divine because
they have omnipotence or
omniscience and so forth but why i
why i had that problem with you is
because you are saying
to be monotheist you also have to be
halton bernoulli
and there's only one entity that's
worthy of worship well i'll disagree
with you i believe in monotheism
but i think that there are entities that
can be worshipped if they are divine and
we will say they're three entities
the father son holy spirit who can
equally be worshipped because
okay that's brilliant thank you i've
learned something new again today and
it's very interesting because what it is
it's like
it's like to us from a certain
perspective it's like
gradual steps towards my knowledge
minority
knowledge yeah so it's it's it's that's
thank you for the i learned a new word
as well today yeah
and so it's it steps towards monolith
that's what we're calling to so if your
definition is going to be
that in that aspect what it shows is
that joshua you are
another step closer in that context from
our perspective here
is that we can see the innate
disposition
calling for that and it's like a step
towards it that might be intentional
unintentional i'm not seeing the
intention of doing that it might be
unintentional
but then again it comes back to the same
point
where if god is the old divine the
all-knowing
yeah the all-powerful the all-seeing the
all-wise
why does he require to share his power
with other entities the question number
one is why would god
require that and secondly for example
isn't it a contradiction to his very
essence because what we say when we
learn this like when we study in these
books
the reason why islam appealed to me so
much besides
the textual scripture like preservation
is that
it was according to pure monetism which
profits before
because you believe in many prophets
yeah and we believe
that's what allah says
not of the people of the book of the
same yeah so
that's the reason why when it comes to
monotheism
monolith yeah it's the only religion
where i found in islam and not only that
i'm not saying islam is true just on
this but i'm saying the nature the human
nature
understands it it clicks with it and
when it comes to for example you have to
do enough explanation now this doesn't
mean it makes it false i'm not trying to
say oh just because you was
no what i'm trying to say is that it's
very simple islam
we single out god in his lordship he's
the all-powerful the all-knowing
okay then we sing him out in worship we
worship him to alone
a lot of christians who come to islam
which is once again i'm not using this
point to prove that islam is right
the main thing that they see is the
following as a catholic i didn't know
mary jesus the spirit and there was a
confusion
joshua can you relate and understand as
muslims
and as someone who's a christian and
those christians who may have
left their faith because it doesn't make
sense that the essence of god and his
divinity is shared why does god need to
share that
can you maybe just answer that question
so i would say to you that god needs to
share it because it's it's
necessitated by his nature necessitated
by his nature
so i would say if god has the property
of being perfectly good
then it requires there to be two
co-equal
divine persons with him so if there's
one divine person
who has we agree the property of
all-powerful all-knowing
and he's perfectly good everything that
he does he does
he um he does a good action um i would
say for being to exist in that way
there has to be two other beings
yeah why two other but not four other or
five okay good good okay
so we can get thank you
i don't get it you don't like me him
heckle me um
yeah what was your question okay good
fine okay
okay so the idea so he's not listening
to his own
voice josh please speak up sorry but
yeah
i don't get it so the idea the idea here
is is that for
for the first for one divine person to
be perfectly good
it needs to inevitably that means from
the beginning there's no
like time that passes it has to bring
into existence
another being so that it can
instantiate so i'm using a big word but
it means like um
uh instantiate just means to make real
the action of loving
so this being will not be perfectly good
if it does not instantiate the action or
perform the action of loving okay
okay your sort of game one thing so now
the idea here is is that there are three
or there's more than this but there's at
least three qualitatively different
forms of love
there is self-love that's just me loving
myself okay
i can live in an island and just love
myself then there is shared
love example of this would be like a
marriage you love your wife she loves
you
you're reciprocating your love and then
there's a cooperation
together in sharing your love so me my
wife we now share our love together
with another being which could maybe be
our child or for some people it's an
animal or whatever but you work together
you love each other and you want to
share your love with that third being
so their self love shared love and
cooperative love
okay now each form of love is better
than the other one
it's qualitatively better so i'm a
better being if i'm not just selfish and
love myself
i'm a better being if i share my love
with another
and i'm we're even a better we're better
together if we're not just
selfish together and say no we don't
want to give our love to anyone we don't
want to help people we don't want to
give our love to a child or
to an animal or whatever we just want to
selfishly love each other
we're better if we cooperate together in
sharing our love with another
so each love is qualitatively better now
the idea here is let's say there is one
divine person who's solely by itself
what it does by itself is well it has
self-love
it loves itself but it cannot
show or exemplify okay
so if you just have a divine person one
divine person let's say
in islam or judaism there's just one
divine person no other beings with it
that being can only instantiate only
show only exemplify
self-love it can't exemplify the
qualitatively better
form of love which is shared love
because there's no other being
so if it existed by itself didn't create
anything there's no other being for it
to share its love with
okay and so the idea here is for that
being to exemplify
a better form of love shared love it
needs to
inevitably bring into existence and
equal entity
who it can share that love with but then
remember
qualitatively cooperative love is better
than just shared love
so if there were just two entities there
will only be quality there will only be
shared love
but remember we we said that there's a
qualitatively even better form of love
which is cooperative love
when two entities share their love
together and then they cooperate
together in
sharing their love with another and so
what the idea here is is that they will
either two of them together they will
bring about uh inevitably bring about a
third
equal to cooperate in sharing that love
with okay
now the question sorry you said because
the idea could be well why would it stop
at three why can't there be another
fourth
divine person or fifth divine person
that they all cooperated and sharing
their love
the issue is is that there is no there's
no qualitative
difference between me cooperating with
one being and cooperating with another
being
so i'll explain it so if i have a wife
here i have a wife i have someone
that i'm sharing my love with and we
work together to share our love with
another being if we shared it with
another being and another being and
another being
the forms of love are not different
remember each step there was self-love
shared love cooperative love but then if
i share it with another
there is no other form of love it's
still cooperative love
there's not a qualitatively greater form
of love than i'm bringing about
so the problem that you'll have then is
that if one of the divine persons brings
about a fourth
or a fifth divine person this will be an
act of the will
and a divine person by definition can
only exist out of necessity
it can't exist because it was willed to
exist it has to exist because it
it's necessary that i exist so the idea
here is if there was a fourth being
that being will not be divine because it
would not be necessary
it would have been a choice to bring
about that being but the second and
third are existing out of necessity okay
all right there's some very interesting
points you mentioned and
once again i don't i personally don't
believe it
justifies and neither does it
answer the very nature of god to have
more than two or for even if we wish to
give it on
the terms of like you said about sharing
that love with the second
and the third yeah and you talked about
necessary existence
and this is it's necessary for it to uh
do it with three but not four
yes so i want to point out something
because it's something that we studied
in
creed books in taharia and it's very
interesting because it touches this
topic because what you're saying is
in order so for example god is the most
merciful
he's the most loving therefore so
there's a discussion happening here
therefore he needs to bring about
you're seeing another divine being in
order to share that love with
now we have this discussion but we have
it with human beings
so what we say is from the get-go we do
not believe god shares his divinity goes
against his nature
however we say this is god still the
all-knowing
the all-lovable uh loving the
all-merciful without creation
so just an elaborate yeah so what we say
is islamically
god is always the all-knowing when for
example there was no creation
god is still the oh merciful when there
was nothing
to have mercy on because that is his
innate attribute
now him carrying that mercy out yeah
for example he will have a creation yeah
so for for him
to for example carry through certain
actions without all loving he
he would uh he will have a creation but
what you're saying is
similar but what you're saying is no he
needs to share his divinity now what
we're saying is the following
we're on same page but in a bit of a
different way because you're trying to
justify
god's sharing his divinity where he's
saying god in his essence is the most
merciful
the all loving and he's always been like
that
he's been he's been like that even when
there was no creation
but you're taking that a step further
and trying to justify
why god needs two free
or more well you're saying it stops that
free the question this means why are you
and you and you said by necessary by
necessity but it goes against it because
we say
by necessity arguments with contingency
yeah so for example
by god god is in this god is a necessary
fact if god is
necessary there can't be nothing like it
so once again do you see as muslims
monolithically
got it right yeah why it's so unique
that we say god doesn't share it it goes
against attribute and by necessity
he doesn't need to to become the all
loving or all merciful he doesn't
need the creation let alone having
another divine being
do you see the problem what we're trying
to pose and we're trying to say that
god almighty in islam is the soul
creator
he doesn't share his divinity he doesn't
need to the moment he says
i need to have another divine being or i
need to yo
what that means is god needs something
to show his
do you have trouble saying so what the
idea here is as i said
god has the property or attribute have
been perfectly good
and defining perfectly good that just
means that this entity will
inevitably that means just out of its
nature perform a good action if there is
one
so if there's a good action there god
will perform it if there's another good
action there god will perform
it you'll just inevitably do it now what
i'm trying to say to you is that there
is a good action
but you're saying to me that god
wouldn't perform it because there's a
good action of
loving that's an action there but
remember we just agreed that
by definition god is perfectly good and
so if there's a good action
he will inevitably do it he will just do
it and so there's a good action there in
front of
god saying love it's called loving
now if god is perfectly good he will
just inevitably
perform the action of loving being in a
loving relationship
but then that requires him that entails
that there is another entity
who it can do who he can love because
what i'm saying to you is that
why not okay good that's a very good
point
because that's not a perfect form of
love a perfect love
is where the love is reciprocated in
quantity and kind
okay so if i'll give you an example why
obviously there'll be loads of reasons
why someone can't do this but why
you can't why you can't um be in a
loving romantic loving relationship with
let's say a child
is because that child cannot reciprocate
the love that you give to it
the love the knowledge everything that i
bestow and give the totality of my being
that i give to that child they won't be
able to give it back to me because they
don't have the mental faculties to be
able to do it
but someone who's equal to me let's say
my wife she can reciprocate in quantity
and kind the love and the totality of
myself
that i give to her she can also give the
totality of herself to me and everything
to me and we reciprocate that
now the problem that you'll have is that
if god does that with creation
it's impossible because creation is not
um equal to god and so they can't
reciprocate
what gives god gives to them because
when you love like i'm saying you give
everything to that entity
well then can god give all of his
divinity all he has all he possesses
which is his divinity to creation no i'm
saying no
i'm saying the question was is that why
can't he share that love of creation so
i'm answering and saying
yeah but i'm saying yeah exactly because
a divine person is only the entity that
can
reciprocate the thing that he gives
because a divine person if i'm divine
and another being divine
and i love that being i give all that i
have my divinity to that being
and that being gives his divinity or
whatever their divinity back to me
they reciprocate everything i give in
quantity and kind
but creation can't do that creation
creative reality by definition is
created
so they can't give divinity back to me
so god can love us
but he doesn't love us perfectly he only
loves us
perfectly if he loves a thing that's
equal to him
and we are not equal to it okay joshua
who sets those standards because what
you're doing now is
you're you're giving the definition of
love yes how love could be um
shared yes but you're given these
standards now this is the reason why in
islam the one of the biggest sins
as [ __ ] is to say something about god he
doesn't he has never said
that's why as muslims we have a dialogue
with christians because we believe
you're uttering something
that god has not verified so now when
you're saying joshua
that god needs something divine to share
it because that's that
and give it its divinity only so it can
give it the same back
what we're saying is number one god
doesn't need human beings let alone
another divine being we say from the
get-go god doesn't need anything
another divine being because it goes
against his nature god doesn't need
human beings from the get-go
that's the reason why we are told that
we only enter paradise by the grace you
would say or by the mercy of allah
because um sorry because the thing is
god doesn't need us we need him
so he shows us his mercy by for example
the things he's blessed us with
the guidance as it shows us and he wants
us to enter his paradise that's why
allah says in the quran
what will i get out of putting you in
the hellfire but seen i don't
you think i'm somebody who's hungry to
people in the fire no
i don't want that for you so the
question that needs to be asked again
is joshua and then what i said to you
god is
all merciful and ongoing or knowing all
loving
even if there was no human beings and no
creation
why does god require another divine
being because it goes against its
essence
because the moment you say he needs
remember what i said i said god doesn't
need human beings
yeah so why does he need another divine
and if he does it goes against nature
because he means
i need love myself and to love well i
know you said
he will be just loving himself so
therefore he needs another divine being
that is not sharing the title the
essence but not the title like you said
and he will love me back why does god
even need that
because remember what i said to you i
said are you going
to take this person thank you um
um okay yeah remember remember
remember what i said to you that there
are different qualitative
forms of love and each one is great or
better than the other remember god has
the attribute of being perfectly good so
everything that he does
would be to the greatest standard so he
wouldn't he wouldn't bring about
at the free uh a worse form of love than
one that's available so if their
self-love their shared love and there's
cooperative love and each one is greater
than the other
if god is just self-loving then he has a
depreciated form of love that he's
instantiating which is a perfectly good
being wouldn't do a perfectly good being
would instantiate the greatest form of
love possible
and that will be qualitatively including
self-love him loving himself
sharing love sharing love with an equal
and then cooperating and sharing love
with another equal
that allows it to be the qualitatively
greatest form of love
you're instantiating each form of love
and each one is greater than the other
so just answering what you were saying
about god being uh
i think all powerful although yeah yeah
so
the problem is is that there's a
difference between being um
let's say perfectly good and loving
performing the action of loving
and being all-powerful or being
all-knowing those are properties that
you have
without any entity you don't need
anything to have it
okay so god is all-powerful without
anything okay he
that just means he has he's able to
perform any action
all knowing means he knows all truths
and he doesn't need anyone to know those
those truths but to be perfectly good
and that means
also being loving that does require
something else and that's what i'm
trying to argue here i'm trying to say
disagree yeah okay oh no i'm just saying
so that certain property that attribute
requires something outside of itself
the other yeah so my problem is is that
where my argument will be
is that it seems then that your view of
god
not your personally but the view of god
that's not arguing the way that i'm
trying to put forward
is an incoherent idea of god because
you're saying god is all powerful
he can perform any action all knowing he
knows all troops perfectly good he'll
perform any good action inevitably if he
does
if there is one but there is a good
action that he doesn't perform
that's contradicting because you're
saying he will perform any good action
if there is one
there is a good action loving shared and
cooperating in love
but he doesn't do that then that means
that he's not perfectly good and so
that's incoherent okay so
the reason okay the reason why i believe
for is it recording that one by the way
okay okay the reason i believe where
like we want to just do respect the
incoherence is coming from your behalf
is because you're making statements
about god that contradicts
nature i'm not contributing this nature
you said something he said he can be the
most powerful
and all-knowing that's within his nature
but in order to be the most merciful and
the
most loving he needs creation
because you're saying that you're saying
how could he be disagree with that but
you said that
no sorry i didn't say most merciful so
mercy i think is
a dispositional attribute of a thing so
it has it it's a disposition that it has
it doesn't need something else to it
doesn't need to exercise it to be
merciful
love is different no so remember what i
said
loving is an action so it's an action
it's not a dispositional property
i didn't say god is is god is god
perfectly loving
okay i said is he loving is he
performing the action of loving
yes so so i'm not arguing i could agree
with you you can be perfectly loving
without anything because that's just a
discipline so
that's just that's that's just a
disposition to be loving
so god is perfectly loving if he just
has a disposition to love
but can god perform that action of
loving and not love
something else that's what i'm saying
okay so what i'm saying is the following
yeah
one thing brother what i'm saying is the
following the reason i believe that
there's incoherence on your behalf is
because
you're attacking the very nature not not
literally here but but what you're doing
is you're going against the very nature
of god by saying
that if he's the loving there must be
something to love
what we're saying is the following god
almighty has always been the loving
when there was no creation because he
had the power to carry the will
out so we can't say you're not all
loving because there was nothing to love
no he had that innately that's his
disposition so what we're saying is
that that can be carried out and god is
the all-merciful i'm specific to all of
him he's
all loving when there was no creation
it's not contradictory because he has
that in his
essence and he chooses to will that if
he created creation
yeah so but when you what you're saying
josh
is that god needs so for example
in order for god to be all loving you're
not even saying he needs a creation
because we can say okay look islam has
that creation he's loving most merciful
wants paradise
what you're saying is he requires
another divine being now what's he
why the stretch and once again
it it doesn't it it's contradictory it
doesn't make sense because
because what you're doing is you're
you're giving some laws but i'm saying
where are you getting this from because
logically speaking logically speaking i
believe the old divine being
the one and only he's the all loving
the all merciful the all-powerful and he
doesn't need anyone to share it with the
moment you say he shares it
it's a contradictory statement to his
very essence
you're doing that i'm saying he's loving
his love is [ __ ]
with the creation you're seeing his love
is shared with another creator
no no listen so remember what i said
though that
the the shared love that god will have
so let's say god creates the world and
shares his love with that world
it will not be a quality the quality the
the best form of shared love
the best form of shared love is sharing
between with an equal
because creation cannot reciprocate the
love i give and this is
this is the way we apply things to
things why i can't go in
sorry doesn't that mean that
god needs love to be sent back to him
yes and i have no problem well the
moment we say god needs
requires so much so that he's going
against his very nature to create
another being
but remember you're saying going against
nature but i'm not saying that i'm
saying
part of god's nature is certain
attributes
all powerful all all-knowing and being
perfectly good
and then part of him being perfectly
good means that he will perform the good
action of
loving and so i'm not going against the
nature maybe it's a nature that you
might
hold to but the nature that i'm arguing
for there is no contradiction in what
i'm saying
i'm saying from this nature it leads to
there being two other divine persons
but if you hold it because the thing is
i think you will not disagree with me
with the attributes i've said
i said to your power i said to you all
knowing it's just we're saying you're
sharing that with another being
yes but i'm saying that third attribute
requires that
so unless you say to me josh perfect
goodness so if god you can say to me
one who came to okay our good master yes
he referred him back to him
yes they're all good yes so if that is
the case of
jesus as one of the divine entities yes
referring back to the all good of the
father yes
that's it's like jesus speaking as a
muslim he's saying the all good is good
don't call me good that's the essence of
all good why does he need to share that
goodness
can i just address that that verse that
verse is not negating the goodness of
jesus
what it's saying is that look to the
source of goodness so but remember what
i said to you
god so the father is understood in a
nominal sense to be god
though and i didn't say though the
reason why he has that
is because he's the source of everything
the ultimate source
if you as you understand with the
trinity ultimate source of everything
even for the sun yes yes so remember
yeah remember we are with the doctrine
of the trinity remember
the father begets the son
and he spirates the spirit so he
generates the son and he generates the
spirit that's the
orthodox understanding of the trinity
that they come from the father
eternally inevitably so the ultimate
source is the father because the father
does not come from anyone else
the father is an uncaused being so he's
the ultimate source
and so the reason why this is why in the
first second third going into the fourth
century
why the father was understood to be the
one god in that sense
is because he is the sole ultimate
source of all reality
and even of the son and even of the holy
spirit
but that doesn't negate from them each
being perfect each being divine
and so the trinity says there are three
divine persons father son and holy
spirit
who are co-equal ontologically with
their divinity
however where there is a distinction is
that the father
is god in the sense of having the name
god because he is the ultimate source of
everything
he brings about the son the spirit and
that is the reason why he has the name
god and that's why jesus points to god
the father says point to the father
because the father is one who's the
source
ultimately of the divinity that the son
has and so the goodness that the son has
comes from him so that's why he's always
pointing back to him so
just just just a few last ones what i
would say is that i'm
as i'm as i can get to the corner as
much as possible i'm trying to
let people understand that there's an
alternative understanding of the trinity
which is not a new understanding but
it's the historical understanding
so the view that i'm trying to argue for
is not a view that just popped out of
nowhere
it is the historical view that was
defined at nicaea
so in 325 and at constantinople in 381
so
the authoritative councils were arguing
for what i said because if you remember
as the council says then i seeing creed
i believe in
one god who doesn't say god is the
father then it says i believe in one
lord
and it doesn't use that term god in a
name for the son
and it doesn't say that for the holy
spirit but it says that they are
homo usus they share the same nature
they are divine as each other but
there's only one who's god and that's
why i'm a monotheist and that's why
trinitarians in this sense
are monotheists because they believe in
one person who is the one true god the
father
and however they are co-equal in their
divinity and that's why they're
trinitarians
so you would be sorry just i am talking
about but you would be you would be a
unitarian
because you only believe in your
monotheist and your unitarian
i'm a monotheist and i'm a trinitarian
so you're monotheism unitarian because
you believe there's one
person who's god and there is only one
person who is divine i'm monotheist
because i believe there's one person
who's god
but i'm trinitarian because i believe
yeah there are three persons who are
divine
is that joshua yes so have you always
hold this position
so this came from my phd research so
when i when i when i was going
um because i i the prior understanding
was the understanding i think you you
and most people you were attacking so
and other people were saying this
if there's a problem with it which i
agree with you that's saying that there
are three divine persons
so they're trinitarians like me three
divine persons but how they would call
themselves monotheists
because they say the trinity is the one
god
so they would say the one god is the
trinity itself the collective of all the
three
i disagreed and that's what i used to
have but looking at the historical text
looking at scripture where it says
there's one true god the father
where jesus says my father my your
father my father my god and your god
where it says paul says there's one god
the father
and one lord jesus christ and then
looking at the historical texts
i realize that actually the position of
trinitarianism was not that position to
say that the trinity is the one god
it was the father who's the one god can
answer your
did you feel a bit more at ease with
what you believe now
oh yes of course because yeah sorry just
international i'm so sorry because
do you not believe joshua yeah and i'll
be honest with you
i genuinely am not here to win an
argument i'm genuinely not here to have
one of you
i genuinely want the best for you as you
want the best for me
do you believe your innate disposition
is is
calling out to
my belief of monotheism and unitarianism
in the context of one divine being
because
the fact that you filter is what you've
discovered recently
would you say joshua is islam what's
stopping you from saying you know what
the concept of islam because i know what
questions i speak to you
and the reason i'm getting personal is
because at the day i just really want to
hear you out here
do you think because i'm not christian i
speak to himself oh muhammad married
oh sorry and all these moral things oh
it doesn't sound good to the ear and to
me how the position
whatever is the truth if god told me you
climb sundays to the
tree get to apple sit down do press ups
and do black flips
i'm doing that and there's a
misunderstanding of the whole the
promised marriage
what's stopping you from coming because
we're saying because
obviously we disagree with this we've
made that clear to the ultimate worship
of the one divine being because to us
what you believe still falls into i do
worship because you're giving
divinity to other beings and attributes
of god to that
what's stopping you from saying you know
what the islamic con
or islam in general what's what's
stopping okay just just